[Music]  what is going on in this crazy place in  this world nothing is what it seems  few moments ago things were different a  lot different I was with my brother with  my connections I could find your brother  no problemo one of them is the world's  greatest secret agent this one over the  last several months a number of citizens  vanished into thin air do you think it's  the same people who took my brother I'm  100% almost sure well well you weren't  the strongest fiercest warriors that can  find no you're gonna pay for your life  in my arena  ooh  [Applause]  he comes here he comes here he comes  Charlie's out there all alone  come on let's motivate  we're heading into dangerous territory  well played  there's no chance of dad's or anything  right  it's okay to be excited to see me you're  only human  [Music]  all right charlie we can develop  [Music]  tell the boss tells here to see Errol I  got a dell down here asking to see miss  cheap no not Odelle they'll be ours  [Music]